m
à l'estaca donc école d'ingénieurs
spécialisée sur les transports et la
mobilité
nous avons entre 10 et 15 % de filles
dans vos promotions ce qui est trop peu
à notre goût qu'à l'instar paristech la
proportion de filles et de 30 % 70 % de
nos diplômés en des postes en recherche
et développement et plus de 20% pour
suivante est ce ces proportions
satisfaisant évidemment j'aimerais bien
la parité mais déjà 30% pour une école
d'ingénieurs scientifique c'est déjà un
taux élevé donc il ya dix ans on a créé
une association qui s'appelle elle bouge
qui aujourd'hui devenue une grande
association avec de multiples écoles et
de multiples partenaires industriels en
son sein dont l'objectif est justement à
travers un système de marrainage de
susciter des carrières l'envi de devenir
ingénieur
nous intervenons avec l'association
elles bougent dans les lycées pour
montrer aux jeunes filles bien que c'est
possible qu'il n'y a pas de frein à
avoir et qu'on a quand on a une
motivation et une envie de faire des
sciences
et bien c'est aussi possible que quatre
garçons et on est très fiers cette année
sur la promotion qui est sorti on
constate une parité de salaire sur nos
diplômés filles et garçons mais c'est
pas le cas dans tous dans tous les
secteurs donc ça c'est quand même
quelque chose qui montre aussi qui est
un progrès
sur le côté technique elles vont
résoudre le problème de la même manière
parce qu'elles ont reçu la même
formation
par contre elles vont intégrer les
facteurs environnementaux des facteurs
sociétaux des facteurs humains que nous
n'atteindrons pas ou moins facilement
les garçons et là je pense que vraiment
les filles ont emmené en garde avance
une équipe avec plus de mixité en
général ça fonctionne mieux
par ailleurs les visions sont
différentes et donc on est aujourd'hui
dans une société alors nous on le voit
particulièrement dans le domaine des
transports où le monde change
on va concevoir pour demain des
véhicules qui sont complètement
différent de ce qu'on connaît
aujourd'hui on a plus de créativité
quand il ya des visions des choses qui
sont différentes et donc les filles ont
une vision qui peut être intéressante
donc c'est typiquement des métiers sur
lesquels elles ont un rôle à jouer